okay hello everyone welcome to another
design review uh heading for version
13.1 of language
and notice the note here that this is
the 599th episode of uh
my live ceoing series here my gosh
it's hard work
um
okay
we are looking at some calculus and
algebra functionality we hope i think
we've covered all that we were just you
was just taking a first peek at
structured arrays yes okay this is a lot
of documentation stuff here yeah um
by the way i i
just i think i've sent some mail about
this i mean there's a lot of stuff with
graphics
where we are under-documented and at a
different different topic
do you agree with that statement or or
are you um
do you want to disagree with that
statement
what specifically are you i mean i'm not
sure exactly what you're thinking of oh
i don't know all kinds of things to do
with labeling and this and that and the
other i mean i keep on seeing under
documentation
yeah i mean there is no real labeling
for graphics
visualization there is but yeah i
understand
um but i mean
so
generally speaking as a as a sort of an
overview i think every reference page
needs to be rewritten to some extent
yeah
there's seven thousand of them so that's
going to take a while yeah i think that
um
uh
well that's fine but i think we need to
these graphics ones are uh and
visualization whatever you call it yeah
the visualization once we are doing that
that's happening all the time
well there needs to be more work
we should go through it separate meeting
sure not for this meeting that's for
sure happening graphics
um we need that we need that to happen
okay so we need that separate meeting
probably yeah okay let's plot all those
things they've got that's visualization
right
there
okay
all right so
the story here is a
this is is this under the hood some kind
of structured array object or is this
yeah so this is a structured array
and
the point of structured matrices and
structured arrays is that they have
short specifications and efficient
computations for a subset of the
computations
now we've done this
framework-wise very much how we built
sparse arrays
and in the sense that
if there is no
special operation
for this class of matrices or class of
arrays
then it will convert it to a normal
array and it will perform the operation
so it should never fail really
so really on the other hand though
right that's zero
no that's just [ __ ] it's wrong
oh parts
yeah it's just wrong yeah it probably
shouldn't do the part
you know
yeah a part shouldn't work it works for
spots arise
yeah but we we're gonna have to look at
this especially then
i think i think sparse array is no entry
or maybe it isn't
well it was zero because i didn't put an
entry there
see it'll work fine yeah that's the
expectation people are going to have is
that that's going to work
yeah
yeah we need to look at that i've got to
make that work
but there could be happen like with
sparse arrays something that you can
represent as a structured array so for
instance
often like a permutation matrix it only
takes a vector to specify
you know and
i understand the point yeah right
i mean okay so so these operations so
another question is in the blob
is that a picture of this actual
permutation matrix or not in this case
it is i think
or maybe that's a generic i mean so no
it looks like it is yeah
i wonder if that's done generally i
don't know how far that stretches if you
make that ten thousand long ike can't
beat that
you know
range ten thousand
well let's just do a range of a hundred
okay
oh
well that's not gonna work it needs to
be cut off somewhere
maybe it doesn't
maybe it's doing something reasonable
here
really is that
right that doesn't seem like it could
possibly be right
no
okay so something is goofy there and
anyway it went from purple to gray
mysteriously
who who's responsible for this somebody
can somebody speak up please yes uh jan
is looking after that so i'll ask him to
fix it i mean he's working with rob as
well but rhiannon is the main person
i'll ask him to fix it
okay
but but you understand i mean so what do
we want to have happen here does this go
through graphic design first question
did this go through graphic design no
nothing goes through graphic design we
use tin okay but you've got to do that
that's part of our process
um no we don't really use graphic design
you've got to do that well only when you
insist on it okay well i'm insisting
okay yeah okay fine
but they're they're not they're usually
not educated in in
in visualization and stuff
well i'm sure it'll be fine okay this is
not going to work right
no i just told you that's not right
yeah so i mean and personally i think
that this you know the purple theme of
this is not very convincing i agree with
you
and i don't know what how it relates to
sparse array and so on
i mean we can we could try and do that
review here if we can find somebody from
design
um
but let's we'll cut to that in a minute
maybe maybe somebody can try and track
somebody jeremy or somebody else down
um okay second point
in here
is there nothing is there nothing else
that is meaningful to say about this
permutation matrix
no
probably not
okay
fine if that's the case so be it
for the other ones there will be but
this one is just
really
okay
so
oh come on
come on what is that
yeah you want it to be a permutation
matrix right so that's not a permutation
matrix
but why is the message text not found
let's have that's a part of the
prototype build process where they can't
get it in okay all right
so what are you telling me about this
this isn't the permutation matrix no
because it must have exactly one uh one
and all zeros in each row oh that's
right that's right that's all
i mean of course yeah
this is
okay
by the way i'm not certain you know
given this okay
maybe this does work
i didn't say earlier but yeah
the part is correct because it's just a
list
yeah i know i know yes i mean
so i think it's all good over there
really
yep
what did you do before
i i just was i was confused because it
said zero but it probably was zero
because most of the permutation matrix
is zero oh yeah
okay i just just got it got confused
you know i hate it saying complexity
order n i would say time order n
yeah
okay fine
um
[Music]
okay
all right what what should i look at
here so i mean this is the beginning so
so to give you the big picture this is
the beginning
of this is like special matrices like we
have special functions
um
the um so we'll we'll add some more
uh we'll eventually open it up so users
can add new ones like this
new families
yeah why doesn't this work shouldn't
this work a signatures
no signature is not defined for matrices
i think signature is a is a thing for a
permutation right no i understand that
but doesn't this no i think look look up
signal i know i understand i understand
i understand i'm saying this is this
defines a permutation
you want the actual property of that
matrix what was what i'm thinking yes i
mean why wouldn't we have it yeah so you
wanted the determinant for it
that's what you want the determinant of
the matrix right
how do we make this matrix represents a
permutation yeah so we could the
question is what is the is it the
determinant of the matrix yes yes it's
the same as the determinant
okay
so i mean for example converting this to
a permutation how would i do that
there's a property
at the bottom you can get
but also that works apparently
okay
did i know that
someone must have done that especially
well yes
it would not you know
there's no way that permutation list
could know about that on its own yeah i
understand
auto complete not working here
not double brackets
just single brackets
now i don't think autocomplete u works
until we've built right
maybe not
think i think
okay nice
so
i'm sorry for a permutation matrix
if i just give it
okay that worked
for an upper triangular matrix i can i
give it the ragged matrix i should be
able to
uh
it didn't seem worth it i don't think
that'll because it it's still harder to
specify that
we could do it but it's like i mean it's
not so useful you should do it there's
plenty of cases where i've had things
where i compute stuff sure exactly this
i mean i i compute stuff by having a
table you know i'll make it up for you i
mean you know table i squared plus j
you know i goes up to
five
you know j goes up to i right right
right yeah so if it looks like one then
it must be one kind of thing yeah yes
yes
i would make that an upper triangular
matrix fine sure right there now what's
the relationship between all the stuff
about diagonal and so on
and banned matrix and all that kind of
stuff to this and banned to this
so that will come back so some of the
things that we've introduced a little
bit too early
like vandoman matrix and
i mean we had to introduce them but an
identity matrix diagonal matrix there
are structured matrices that can be done
very efficiently these ones are not they
will just generate a
matrix um which which now which is not a
bad thing the identity matrix is a fine
thing to generate and very useful and
don't mess with it right no but we need
a second argument that allows us to get
it out in different forms
yeah
no doubt as as of many different kinds
of things i mean yes permutation matrix
or this or that or the other many
different structured matrices but
presumably if i take this and i say
permutation matrix of this
i will get the right thing identity
yes
right but i mean what what you'll
but your point is
i'm just trying to understand the
pattern here so the pattern is that
there is this is something that kept
coming up right so for us and for our
users when you're trying to push certain
functionalities so fandom on comes up
when you solve interpolation problems
uh tokens i understand the reason for
these matrices i'm asking a different
question which is the in the in the
pattern
of you know identity matrix which is
ordinarily an ordinary expression
but
what you want is a case where you can
generate the special representation
without having to generate the
non-special representation and then
specialize it so exactly right okay so
i'm asking what the pattern for how we
represent that i think a candidate
pattern is that there is a second
argument i think identity matrix
actually already has that can generate a
sparse array
but
yeah it does
look i i would argue
i would argue that there may be value in
having an option
perhaps in addition to a second argument
but a general option
i don't know target structure or
something like that
i don't know if that's right
well it would be kind of nicer but
normally we've avoided that because it
sort of changes the form in some way
yes except that the argument here is it
doesn't in fact change the semantics
because these things are just
you're right absolutely not
i would be in favor of that it's cleaner
so as far as i'm concerned it's a
cleaner solution yes i agree
so if you're okay with it stephen i'm i
think that's a great idea
i'm probably okay target structure maybe
arrow and then the the name
but now
i mean
i wasn't gonna say the the question
uh
i lost what i was gonna say okay
um
right all right let's keep going here so
then
um
[Music]
okay
now i mean i assume that the the
operations you are describing
here
have the feature i mean the determinant
just gives an integer back an inverse
presumably gives well i don't even know
an inverse of a upper triangular matrix
doesn't give an upper triangular matrix
so it gives some no no it gives an upper
triangular matrix it's closure closure
it's closed under that okay all right
but but
um but it doesn't in general in general
you can't
you know these structured
matrices they've come up for different
sort of purposes and they don't have
closure under everything
so it's it then will have to get uh you
know to a normal matrix right so there's
a good reason to have this target
structure option because it could be
that there's a
case where you want to try and make it
if you can make it sparse you want to
make it sparse and so on
right
okay i've got another question here and
then we have jeremy here we talk about
some graphic design
um
my question is
about data structure i think we just
briefly touched on that before you
mentioned something right should these
matrices be data structures i think yes
um so they all structured a race with a
list of operations basically so we built
a system that works for these
that
you know when you come to an operation
it will check whether there is a
specialized operation and if not
it will norm you know make it a normal
matrix and
no i understand that but i'm saying when
you're dealing with a compiler for
example yes dealing with you know we
definitely you know sparse arrays are
definitely a thing that the compiler can
understand
surely we want upper triangular matrices
to be another thing that the compiler
can understand
and for that could be the case
we we can work with i mean sir rob and
jose has been key part of sort of
building the framework we're now
um filling it in basically with concrete
structure raise but they're also the
right you know rob in particular in the
compiler team would be the right to sort
of figure that out whether we can get
that right more detail
yeah right i think it's a computer
because i think i think data structure
will pursue that i don't know if it's
data structure but compiler integration
i understand completely
yeah okay
i think it's going to be useful to have
it as a data structure because i think
it's going to be you know at the very
least
even if it's identical in functionality
to to what is provided in the top-level
expression you know when people look
through the list of data structures and
it's like can i use these things as data
structures that will be a place you know
that would be a useful thing we'll look
into that for the next cycle sure okay
that would be a framework extension
definitely okay for jeremy we are
looking at these blobs and um i i don't
know
i mean
is there a blob
uh
gallery somewhere no we didn't prepare
we can do that but but we don't have it
i mean
okay but i mean
we're using this purple
you're using this purple motif
everywhere except that you don't have a
purple motif there it's red for some
reason i honestly haven't really
seriously looked at that you know we
wanted to get there were more other
challenges to get over
so
well so maybe we're not maybe we can do
this offline with jeremy i mean i think
i think my only point is
you know purple is is a color
i just i don't know what it's gonna it's
gonna mean something i don't understand
what this palette is i don't know how it
relates to other things i don't know why
those symbolic things are red
i agree with you we but but i also i'm
just saying i haven't really thought
about it because there were more serious
things
yes initially to get over okay but do we
think we have a pattern for you know in
these summary blobs
for what the color palette is for
different kinds of things no i want to
go over it first okay all right fine
well then then this is a null discussion
sorry
uh
so i think
jeremy you you're that's fine and i can
follow up roger if you want to pull me
in yeah that would be great jeremy
so so what we'll put together is what i
do i couldn't even tell you what the
design is right now so there's a bunch
of questions i have and then we'll put
together a gallery what it is and then
let's come up yeah it should be fairly
straightforward okay all right okay
thanks jeremy
um
okay all right so i think i understand
these matrices the
okay block diagonal matrix so that is
something very related to the band
discussion isn't it
no
yes
no
look
we have this mechanism
for black diagonal matrices if i'm not
mistaken
band
a banded matrices is a thing but no i
know but but there's a way of doing
block diagonal
okay what does lower triangular eyes do
on
okay so here's another question lu
decomposition
does that give what does that do with
respect that that would be a good
place for a target structure to make
sense
yes and so the idea is to be able to
shift you know so all these matrix
decomposition algorithms they produce
basically structured matrices that are
then easy to work with and now they can
return these things that are both easy
and efficient to work with
right but so lower triangularize can
have a target structure option
that can say
uh lower triangular matrix
good idea yes yes yes definitely
okay
all right i'm trying to understand
there's somewhere what the heck is this
why is the stuff what was that
that was the thing where i hit the tv it
was like a tv
look look
it it was a thing this is a bug and so
if somebody could mark the time code
here and try and figure out what i do
because that's happened to me multiple
times and i think it's something to do
with the way focus is working on this um
uh input field here
i've got that
okay i don't know how it did that
okay
that's another one
we don't have it yet but
we'd like to go back and structure that
if it's requested basically yeah but
we don't have it yet but yes yes but
this is gonna be a mess right because
here
this is called diagonal matrix
and you can't return a thing called
diagonal matrix why not
because we
we have many things that are both
constructors and representers
i guess
i guess well this is a good reason to
have an option because we've got all
kinds of arguments hanging out here
um
i think it's also interesting this
target structure thing might also be
interesting to return data structures in
some cases not for this not for this
family of things but in other cases
yes just a more general option yes
okay
uh so what we're looking at i was still
trying to remember how we done block
diagonal matrices before we've had a
mechanism for doing them what is it
the best i know is i mean roger would
know better but there is a wfr function
but that's about all i know about
we've had a very rough tough time i've
had to write this function myself every
time i use it so we need for things like
you know uh the decomposition that we
did for
like the core nil potent another thing
that we did for
the earlier release so we need this
ourselves the block diagonal matrix okay
let me look at it
okay
well i wouldn't have given that example
but whatever i mean
doesn't seem like the right example to
give it seems like the example you want
to give is something which has a a
matrix of different sizes
we can change that here
and i'm not suggesting this particular
one for now but but
oh gosh and if i say normal of this
yes then she'll just give me the right
and you can say matrix form to get the
matrix form etc
this is a mess
because
you know what i this is a mess
you know diagonal matrix identity matrix
they just give you back the matrix
this is incredibly hostile to people
people are going to get really confused
they're going to say
identity matrix gives me a matrix but
permutation matrix just returns some
weird permutation matrix thing
how do we
how do we deal with that so like in the
case of this you know
block diagonal matrix
you know some of the time i'm just going
to want to get the normal version of
that and we've got a confusion of names
of some things returning the normal
versions and some things not so how do
we deal with that
well i mean i guess if we do the target
structure option
we could get you know you th even these
constructors could have that
yes no they absolutely could the
question is what the default is for
smart
i really think that the default should
be to to return the structured thing
otherwise we're stuck with inefficient
no but that's not true for a three by
three thing
it might be true for a thousand by
thousand thing
i mean for many purposes for small ones
people are not going to want the
structured thing
yeah so if we make it automatic and then
it sometimes does it and sometimes
doesn't
i'm not sure i mean if we've managed to
get the plumbing correct that would be
okay
well i mean first of all i was going to
suggest we introduced this as
experimental for now until we have a
little bit more and a little bit more of
the pattern
sort of
you know fleshed out
i think it's it's let me think about
this for a second i mean let me just
think about for a second
there really two ways to think about
this i mean one is the way that we do
pact arrays for example
where the thing walks and talks like the
ordinary expression
just happens that internally it starts a
more efficient way
but it fails mysteriously for people
only in terms of speed
and storage
yeah it doesn't i understand
but that's a different issue that's a
different problem than the problem of it
being you know this is where we make a
mistake so many times no like it's like
elementary no no i mean if we just want
to be a toy system we can yeah but we
don't we want to we want to actually be
it so that people can understand and
they don't like want to pick up their
computer and throw it across the room
because it did something that they don't
understand
okay so
let's
what i think
you know the best way to do this would
be
that
it basically is invisible
this is something which internally you
say permutation matrix just makes a
matrix just looks like a matrix
but internally it's a much more
efficient representation where
its display form
is
that permutation matrix blob whenever it
gets big which is much more useful than
a tiny piece of some giant thousand by
thousand matrix
but we need rob here in this discussion
if this is gonna go anywhere because i
think that
this is gonna be blocked on that
that it's not doable i mean i know you
like that but just
yeah well
make it experimental
i mean i think it it
i think we should consider
making this target structure our
automatic thing
for now
where the real solution is
this
you know
invisible data structure solution
and this is an imitation of that which
will be plug compatible
assuming that all the plumbing is done
correctly
we need i mean no i'm not committing to
it without rob in this discussion
because it's it's it may or may not be
doable it may be sort of prohibited but
you understand what i'm suggesting what
i'm saying is if the plumbing is correct
it doesn't matter whether you have the
blob whether you have the literal
expression there you'll always get the
same results
for every operation right
okay so if that's not true
then
you know like for example length what
does that what does length do here
i mean maker
lovely
weird well i don't know if that's weird
is that that right i'm not even sure
um
it is okay well you know we may already
have the solved
and it's really just a question of what
you know it's almost just a question of
print forms
right
i mean maybe this is completely solved
already
and i mean what happens if i do map on
this
it's fine
yeah i'm sure
jose has gone through a long list of
things like map and all that he's got a
checklist which he goes through every
time for these things
well this may be just a question of
print forms i i can have agree because
it even to me it looked like for a small
matrix if it's possible then to show the
actual matrix would be much nicer
this is a bit frustrating to do a matrix
form of that
right the only thing that might not work
is if you select an element
interactively given that you see the
matrix right but i think that's a minor
issue honestly yes
uh
okay
yeah because i think people are just
going to want to say
okay i personally think it would be
nicer to make the normal expression for
small cases but i'm not certain about
that that's a question for rob we'll
follow up okay stephen i understand
where you're standing and that's
actually where i was trying to get it to
several you know rounds ago
fine okay
all right
uh
any more on the on the matrices um
not really i think that as i said we
will evolve this and fill this in and
then open it up so that people can
create their own
as well
i mean just just so i understand i mean
there's also structured tensors too yes
this is this is called structured erase
there's a guide page for it
okay all right fine so we're expecting
structured you know block diagonal
tensor and things like that too
yeah we even have a structured vector
right now called like unit vector
right
okay well look if we do this thing with
this illusion
then
you know it almost becomes the case that
we could change the return value of
block diagonal
of of um
uh what am i thinking of of of um
oh diagonal matrix diagonal matrix right
and nobody would know the difference
right
um
okay
all right uh what else do we have to go
over what's this model predictive
control design well this was i don't um
this was when we had more optimization
so this use we already had that design
review
but that was
an application for optimization but that
shouldn't have been left and now that we
had okay cut out the other things so
sorry about that
but sometimes
okay
multiple support
so
i mean this is what we introduced in in
130 right the center yes
yes yes
okay
well this is a lot of work and very
important but not
probably what i
what we should
i mean this is really important stuff i
don't know what i let me do it's
happened
yeah well let's pick a random one and
look at it
mostly it dies works very nice work
on it's just gone the whole page and
rewritten everything
and where they were before that is also
worth commenting there are like five
examples do we really want a thing like
this
under applications only yes we allow
that
it should be under applications only
that's the only thing that's reload
yeah it is okay fair enough i mean
there's a lot of work over here it's
a major project finished
well it's super useful it is
wow
okay i mean we should think about how we
can leverage this as we get more and
more of these
more educational more complete pieces
yeah we need for the the lineage of mooc
we thought the documentation was not
adequate at that point so this kind of
will help people who go to the course
and then look at a documentation to
learn it from you as well in more depth
that is the whole idea actually
fine sounds good all right anything else
we need to review here
i think we covered ever could you just
scroll to the bottom but i think you
covered everything
well let's take a look here this is some
yeah we released the differential
equations class
great
algebras should be done in next three
months
module calculus january 2023
and probability we just starting off
we'll probably have it sometime next
year
book forms those courses will be nice
too uh we're exploring that as we speak
yes we're working with the wolfram media
folks
okay
and that they will they'll act as course
books i mean
would they be books in a similar format
to like e-iwl and etienne's book or um
you know nice frankly
what's that says again they may not be
as nice because i mean i think that what
we'll do initially is to have them
mirror the course with you know like
transcript based things
so people can actually use them as the
known folks and then we slowly take it
to the next roger we're seeing something
yeah
we have a we have a longer game plan
where we want to build this is this is
also for another time i want to discuss
that with you steven
where we build
books that you can buy
or you can get them for free distributed
if you're
if you have mathematica and you we have
a bookshelf in the product where you add
in your books
yeah fair enough well i mean that
relates also to the courseware
repository yes also being worked on have
you been connected to those guys
have you no
way i mean i vaguely heard about it but
i don't know what's happened there
well what they've been mostly doing is
building the question framework
right building the assessment framework
and the question framework which is now
in pretty advanced state okay
okay and presumably these courses use
that or we'll use that
i thought we already did use that maybe
you use a more current version of it a
problem it's been it's probably an
earlier version yeah
it's been productized i mean it's
probably the things that we use for eiwr
we're an early version
yeah so i think that that's what we've
been using for calculus and linear
algebra etc right so that's been
productized and
then the next step for that team
is the courseware repository
okay
and i probably haven't seen that that uh
who who's saying i think is a relevant
brady okay right
um good
and uh yeah i think it's highly relevant
uh
and have you been using the the um those
recording tools that were originally
made for me for doing recording of
course material
with all those um
you know the thing that has that whole
thing that you run on an ipad
that talks about next
next example and so on
i think some people like it the
elementary algebra people like that
pattern
and so i think the more modern courses
after the first couple are using them
and they have because most of it takes
place at home nowadays with people not
able to come on site even so far but yes
that's being used quite nicely and the
kind of stuff that dave what office is
that what you're referring to i don't
know whether they've used it i don't
know
but i think we use it quite a lot for
the elementary algebra because it makes
sense over there so there's usually two
stages to writing these courses one is
to to sort of come up with a syllabus
and write it out then there's the second
stage where there's more editing and
recording going on right yeah
so that's some either word from your
team or someone else
have you guys seen that hands book
brother with the printed version yes yes
um all right anything else here
no no okay oh shoot i am in such trouble
bye
see you bye